david manga talent on s'attend
maintenant à l'arrivée des maillots de
l'équipe de france il était temps
mais une gestion particulière les
maillots vont arriver au compte gouttes
comment ça se passe et nouveaux magasins
alors on espère
en recevoir entre 50 et 75 pour
l'ensemble des magasins intersport donc
du réseau inter sport en martinique donc
un tas sport au robert intersport au
lamentin et intersport a dit non
après il faudra faire attention au
niveau des répartitions détail pour les
séries limitées
donc en être enfin il faut vraiment
tenir compte des tailles s m l xl double
xl
donc ce sera pas pour tout le monde l'a
vraiment l'impression que nike qui est
le fournisseur de l'équipe de france a
décidé vraiment de jouer sous la
stratégie du compte goutte la pénurie
exact c'est exactement ça le nike
aujourd'hui mon vous savez que il ya
plusieurs types de communication donc la
communication par l'amour
la sensualité et aussi la communication
par la peur par la frustration est là en
l'occurrence on est on est exactement
dans ce cas là donc la communication par
la frustration
on peut avoir des craintes concernant le
prix du maillot en général sur le réseau
et à ce porc on est sur les prix de
vente
conseiller donc on ne surent marche pas
donc le maillot authentique était à 140
euros
nous on général on en parlera et
authentique
on allait maillot réplica qui sont aux
alentours de 80 85 voix 89 euros ou sont
au maximum
est-ce que vous avez 2 à vis des
demandes depuis la victoire de l'équipe
de france
oui bien sûr on en a on a chaque jour on
pensait même que l'effet sur serait
retombée mais la communication de nike
est tellement maîtrisé que ben
aujourd'hui la demande est forte et les
gens les gens cherchent le maillot du
premier maillot voir arriver quand les
premiers maillots sont déjà en livraison
donc
à partir de mi-août donc pas par le
biais des réseaux intersport donc je
pense que ça devrait arriver d'ici la
fin du mois de fin du mois d'août